panels uh the government panel
uh and then the industry speakers panel
and then we'll take susan uh
sorry i should introduce their property
as the editor-in-chief of national
graphic
front row and we'll bring the english
and panelists up um
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen um
in this week of
what i would call global speed dating um
i'm i'm so happy to see all of you here
from different walks of life from all
parts of the world
to discuss a topic which is
one of the most politically
charged issues that has
caught the attention of the world's
population
north south east west everyone sees we
have a problem with plastic
and everyone knows we need to solve it
and that's that's urgent
everyone knows that if we don't do
something about this
plastic will suffocate our oceans will
cause
ever worse health problems
for human beings we find micro plastics
in every drop of water
we find micro plastics in every living
being on earth almost
and our oceans are clogging up marine
life
is suffering we need to do something
about
this and what i find inspiring that
we've reached a point
that this is no longer the issue for
trailblazers for people who've known
this
for so long this is an issue that is
picked up by politics
by society by industry by ngos
so let's do something about it and i
think this is one of those issues
where even if everybody's on the same
page we still need
regulation to make sure that we head in
the right direction
that is why at the european commission
we have decided to
launch a plan to make plastics more
circular
but also to ban plastics for which we
have perfectly
feasible alternatives so without much
pressure on the consumer we can still
change the way we live and change the
way
we use plastics you know a simple straw
we
use to drink a soft drink or water
it's produced in a few seconds you use
the perhaps five minutes
and then it takes about 500 years to
break it down and what is left are still
micro plastics that will still
be in our natural environment we want
this not to be the age of plastics where
our archaeologists in a couple of
thousand years will find a whole layer
of plastics
that will define our age we want this to
be the age when we turn around and when
we make sure that we take responsibility
for our natural environment and for our
health
i'm so excited uh to be here with eunep
today
eric solheim is on his way he'll be here
soon um
i'm really really grateful to national
geographic to be one of our out there as
eric
welcome to be one of our sponsors and
susan goldberg is here
to moderate our um session today
but let me just end by saying
that um make a confession
um sylvia earle for me
is right up there with nelson mandela
and bruce springsteen as my personal
heroes
um really
um there's only one difference between
her
and wonder woman she's for real
and she has done so many amazing things
when we were still
not on the same page without people like
her
who finally got our attention after so
many years of being one of the most
outstanding marine scientists in the
world
she got us where we need to be i think
and you know i am deeply honored to be
sitting next to her
and i am very much looking forward to
what she has to say to us
sylvia